-We're both
gonna get the same item.
The first person
to guess it wins.
-Okay.
-All right. Let's do this.
-Yep.
All right.
-All right.
[ Audience "Ohs" ]
♪♪
[ Audience screams ]
-Do you smell that?
What?
It's, like, food.
♪♪
-Smells like...
[ Audience screams ]
-No.
♪♪
I think it's food
for, like, a duck.
No?
♪♪
-Oh, my God!
-What? What?
[ Buzzer ]
-It is so gross.
It's, like,
maggots or something.
-No!
-What are they?
-Oh, my gosh!
-Oh, my God.
-What were they?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?
-Those are mealworms.
♪♪
[ Audience "Ohs", laughter ]
-Ha!
Go for it.
-Ah.
Here we go.
[ Inhales sharply ]
[ Cheering ]
-Oh. Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
Go for it.
-No, but he said
something weird.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
♪♪
-Aah!
Gross!
-What the heck?
-Ooh!
Ew!
[ Laughter ]
It's -- uh, uh, a egg?
-Yeah.
-Egg?
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-That was a lot.
-Usually the first one
is kind of easy.
-You barely touched it.
-I touched it enough.
I touched it enough
to know what it was.
-Okay.
-It was --
I didn't like its viscosity.
-Okay.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughing ]
Oh.
Oh-ho-ho!
[ Audience screams ]
♪♪
-I feel like it's hair.
-Yes!
It is hair.
Oh, my -- Wow!
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
How did you --
You have guts, man.
-I don't even want to see it.
Just -- Just go away.
[ Laughter ]
That's so gross.
No!
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
My turn again.
Oh, no!
-[ Laughs ]
-I feel like the rounds
get crazier.
-Oh.
[ Cheering ]
[ Audience "Ohs" ]
♪♪
-I don't --
-Whoo!
[ Audience shouting ]
♪♪
-Yeah?
-No! I didn't feel anything.
I'm just freaking out.
[ Laughter ]
-You can do it!
-Gosh, oh, gosh, oh, gosh.
-Come on.
-All right.
♪♪
Aah!
[ Audience shouting ]
♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
-Is it like a tongue
or something?
-Oh.
-Is it like a chicken
or a tongue or something?
-Nope.
It's a brain.
-Ew!
What the --
What?!
[ Laughter ]
Wait.
What in the what?
-Is it real?
No, it's not real.
-Is that a real brain?
-It's a cow brain.
-It was cow brain?
Get Purell right now.
This is insane.
-Ew.
[ Laughter ]
-What's wrong with people?
Okay, get this out of the way.
This is good.
All right.
The final round.
-Is this the final?
-Well, it is for me. Sure.
-Okay.
-That was
the final round right there.
Cow brain.
All right, this is up to you.
-What do I do?
[ Audience "Awws" ]
That's sad.
What do I do?
-All right,
you do the same thing.
-I do it?
-Yes, you do it.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience screams ]
-Is it my dog?
No.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
I don't know what the [bleep]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hey! hey!
Come on.
-I'm sorry.
-It's a family show!
You see what you made her do?!
-I'm so sorry.
-You see what you made her do?!
You see what you made her do?
-Oh, that's so cute.
-Wait. I get cow brain,
and she gets a stuffed animal?
[ Laughter ]
-I'm so sorry.
-Get this thing out of here.
I can't believe it.
-I'm sorry.
-We're doing an abbreviated
version
of the show, and we're going
to start kind of mild
with Los Calientes.
But I'm going to be honest
with you guys.
It's a very steep ramp-up.
We very rapidly get to the last
dab of hot sauce,
more than 400 times hotter
than a jalapeño.
[ Audience oohs ]
So with that in mind,
are you ready to dig in?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, okay.
So we just go with this one?
-This one, right? No?
-I think you're at the end
of the paddle.
And then we'll all --
-That looks way hotter, though.
-It has pieces of pepper
and stuff hanging in there.
I've seen the show, you should
eat the whole thing?
-If you're down to commit.
-Oh, yeah.
I'm down.
-These are good.
-Okay, mild. That's good.
You can handle spicy?
You can do that?
-It's not bad.
-All right, Jimmy,
my first question is for you,
because as I understand it,
a few years ago, you did
a segment called "Cooler Heads"
with James Franco.
And there was this gag
where they were supposed to take
a bucket of fake Buffalo sauce
and dump it over your head.
But because of a production
mix-up,
it ended up being real hot
sauce?
-Yes. Very real.
-Really?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh,
it was unbelievable.
I don't know -- That person is
no longer working at the show.
[ Laughter ]
He dumped real Buffalo wing
sauce all over my head
and we finished the thing,
and I'm like, "That was great!"
And then I just started
feeling a tingling on my face
and on my back, it went down
the back of my shirt.
And my whole face was kind of
scarred from cayenne pepper.
And I took a shower in milk.
-It's always
a professional liability
when you are working with
extremely hot sauce.
I know that better than anyone.
Are you guys ready
to move on here
to the Wiltshire
Chilli Farm sauce,
featuring Trinidad Scorpion?
For many years, the hottest
pepper in the world?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, great.
-Trinidad Scorpion.
♪♪
Okay, that's something.
That's something there.
[ Laughter ]
I'm feeling something.
I feel something.
-It's actually not bad.
-Really?
-Selena's rocking it.
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
-Make some noise for Selena.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Really?
You're not freaking out?
-Unh-unh.
-My tongue -- something is
happening.
[ Laughter ]
-All right, Selena,
this question is for you.
From eating pizza crust
and fried pickles,
your food preferences
very much bear the mark
of somebody who does not
apologize for what she likes.
So with that in mind, can you
explain the enduring allure
of dining out at Hooters?
-Well, initially it was to --
[ Laughter ]
-You can just get
right to the end of the story.
-Okay.
-Whoo-hoo!
[ Laughter ]
[ Barking ]
Oh, God!
Trinidad Scorpion.
Are you serious?
-Initially, it was because my
dad wanted to hit on hot girls.
-Ah.
-But then, I just --
I don't know -- I enjoy the
fried pickles, the shrimp,
the butter.
-Uh, yeah, that's good.
-It's good.
[ Laughter ]
-Great menu. Great menu.
-Could not have said it better
myself.
All right.
-Oh, no.
-Right? Are you feeling this?
-I think I am now.
-Now you're feeling it.
-Well, for people who watch
"Hot Ones,"
this is the moment
they've been waiting for.
This next wing is
Da' Bomb Beyond Insanity.
It is a ride.
[ Laughter ]
-Wha--
-Selena, you're awesome, cheers.
-Cheers.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Sizing it up.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-You're crying. You're crying.
Oh, my God.
-What the hell?
[ Laughter ]
-So this sauce is just
all about survival right now.
We're just trying to
survive this segment.
On our show we have
a recurring segment
called "Explain That 'Gram,"
where we have our guests explain
their Instagram pictures.
-[ Coughing ]
-So can we put it up?
Do you remember this selfie, and
what the heck is in your teeth?
-I don't remember anything
right now.
[ Laughter ]
-You were -- what was it --?
-This is horrible.
-Aah! What was in it? Gum?
Do I have to finish all of this?
No disrespect, right?
-It was gum! It was gum!
-Oh, my gosh. Okay.
I think it was gum
or lipstick or something.
Oh, my God.
-From four years ago,
what a memory.
What a memory.
All right, you probably wonder
why I'm shaking up this bottle.
This is the last dab.
We call it the last dab
because it's tradition
to put a little extra
on the last wing.
[ Audience ohhs ]
You don't have to if you don't
want to.
-Oh, my God.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
My nose is running.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
All right. I got you.
Oh. Oh, gosh.
Ooh!
[ Audience ohhs ]
Oh. All right.
-All right. Bottoms up.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
All right, you guys have had...
-I hate it!
-...so many iconic moments on
"The Tonight Show" together.
But now it's time to put another
chapter in the history books.
We'll do a name that impression
game.
Jimmy, all you have to do is
ad-lib three impressions.
And, Selena, all you have to do
is try to guess the impression.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Groaning ] Ugh, I just
want to say who I'm doing.
Uh...my gosh.
[ Sighs ]
Geez, like, Sandy, I swear to
God, I can't believe this.
I can't even do an impression.
It's killing me.
[ Laughter ]
Just say John Travolta.
-John Travolta.
-[ Hysterical laughing ]
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
You're crying. Just please
say Pee-Wee Herman.
-How is that Pee-Wee Herman?
-Look at you crying.
Just one more.
-Why do you do this to people?
[ Laughter ]
-We're stuck here together.
-You're an evil, evil man.
You're a sick, evil man.
And how are you not crying?
Wait, you haven't eaten
your wings!
Oh, my gosh.
Last one.
I haven't even touched it yet.
Oh, my gosh. Hey, hey.
[ Speaking gibberish ]
There's nothing in that.
-What are you doing?!
-Adam Sandler.
-Thank you, say Adam Sandler.
Just say Adam Sandler.
-It is Adam Sandler!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I don't know if you know this.
But you have something in common
with Billie.
You're an inspiration
for the song "Bad Guy."
But not you.
-Am I the bad guy?
-You're not the bad -- no.
-No, I'm kidding.
-The theme song of
"Wizards of Waverly Place"...
[ Cheers ]
...was an inspiration --
[ Cheers and applause ]
was an inspiration to her --
to getting the tune.
-That's --
-Isn't that bizarre?
-I love you.
-So, I thought maybe
it'd be fun to play --
-I love Billie.
-...to play a little bit
and see if we can see...
-Oh, gosh. Okay.
-...what inspired her.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
-Here's a little bit
of "Wizards."
-Okay.
-Okay?
-Oh, no.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-♪ Well, you know everything
is gonna be a breeze ♪
♪ That the end will,
no doubt, justify the means ♪
♪ You could fix any problem
with the slightest of ease ♪
♪ Yes, please ♪
-Oh, my God!
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Ba, ba-doo doo ♪
-Yeah.
-That's kind of -- right?
Here's "Bad Guy."
[ "Bad Guy" plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-That's so cool.
-Kinda, right?
Isn't that cool?
-That's so cool.
-That's pretty fun.
I think that's cool.